if this works sign me up for the
Olympics okay so today I'm going to be
making a giant chocolate Easter Egg one
of my favorite things to eat on Easter
morning first I'm just gonna melt down
the chocolate I'm using semi-sweet
chocolate I'll use two bags for now
we'll see maybe we need more when you're
melting chocolate it burns super quickly
so I'm just gonna do 1 minute intervals
and stir it and keep doing that until
it's melted down the coconut oil will
also help with setting the chocolate
into the egg shape too so I think it's
just like a win-win situation to use the
coconut oil the chocolate seems like a
nice consistency though to spread around
the balloon so I'm hopeful about that
now we have our bottle filled with
chocolate I'm gonna overcompensate a
little because I know I'm gonna lose so
I'm a little lightheaded
boom I'm gonna twist it to create kind
of a seal before I try to snap this
around this squeeze bottle dang it I
have like a phobia of balloons popping
just seeing a hose that
[Music]
this is the perfect thing for me to be
doing I'm a little nervous cuz this is
like do or die let's flip this oh okay
something's happening definitely I'm
gonna need more chocolate so there is a
chance I can't do this by the way so I'm
gonna maybe tilt it this way so hard to
tell where it needs to go I'm just gonna
roll it around a lot I feel like this is
like Tetris or something oh my god I
think I did it if this works sign me up
for the Olympics this should work as
like a little nest the inside is chalk
so I'm gonna freeze it this is a better
freezer 30 minutes and I'll check on it
see if it's like solid because coconut
oil helps chocolate set super quickly so
it shouldn't take too long
we'll see stay tuned it's pretty hard so
I'm happy with that so I'm just gonna
cut the balloon now and hopefully peel
it off okay here whoa whoa that was so
satisfying yeah it's definitely more of
a round egg not the great decorator
let's get that out there first it was
pretty fun though I have to say a little
messy I feel like I'm just trolling this
egg to do some sprinkles alright I think
that concludes the decorating portion do
you like it
Happy Easter well looks like Easter just
threw up all over this chocolate egg
tune in next time for another super mega
challenge oh yes
[Music]